hello and welcome to amcoding this is
James Murphy I am doing another giveaway
so if you'd like a professional license
to pycharm which is the editor that I'm
currently using then check the
description in this video we're going
over whether or not a bunch of built-in
things in Python make copies of your
data
this is actually inspired by one of my
previous videos I had a lot of
commenters rightfully worried that
looping over a list this way in order to
Loop over it backwards might be making a
copy I got suggestions to use a slice of
a list instead
and in the wild I've even seen people
fall back to using error-prone indices
just to avoid this issue well it's
definitely clear this index-based
approach doesn't make a copy of my list
but it's so much less readable
so I'm happy to tell you that reversed
does not make a copy of your sequence if
you want to Loop over something
backwards this is the way to do it this
isn't a foolproof method to tell whether
or not a copy is made but we can
actually get an inclination that one is
not made by printing out the Reversed of
the list notice that instead of getting
an actual list back we get this list
reverse iterator object
if you see something that says like an
iterator or a view or a generator that
should be a clue that a copy probably
isn't being made just for comparison
notice that if we use this fancy slice
of a list then we actually get another
list back so although it's shorter in
this case it is also making a copy
so then how is reversed able to Loop
over the list without making a copy
well here's an implementation of a class
that acts the way that reversed does
the key idea in all of these ways of
iterating is to Define your own iterator
an iterator is just an object that you
can repeatedly ask for elements
the way that you ask it for an element
is by calling its next method
this is also what's called by the
built-in next function
if there are any more elements left to
iterate over then next Returns the next
one
if there aren't any more elements to
iterate over you signal that by raising
a stop iteration
technically speaking an iterator must
also have an itter method that returns
self
this is a little bit confusing because
the magic itter method is used to define
an iterable not an iterator
iterables are just things that you can
ask for an iterator from
whereas an iterator you can think of
more as an in-flight stream of elements
so all the return self really says is
that if you want to get a stream of
elements from a stream of elements just
return the Stream
most of the important logic is in the
next method
so all we do when we construct the
Reversed object is store reference to
the sequence initialize an index to the
last element of the sequence
and do some error checking every time
you ask a reversed for the next element
it gives you the element at its current
index and then subtracts one from the
index the last or I guess first valid
index is zero so after returning that
one our index gets set to -1 so if we
see minus one then we know there are no
more elements
so as you can see this allows us to
iterate over the entire sequence without
making a copy of it the built-in reverse
is actually going to do something more
like this that actually does things in
terms of this next method a common way
to do something similar without as much
code is to use a generator instead
this generator code does essentially the
same thing is quite a bit clearer in
what it's doing but the major difference
here is that the error checking doesn't
happen until you actually start the
generator which happens when you
actually ask for the first element
whereas the class solution did the error
checking in its init function of course
doing error checking earlier rather than
later is usually a good idea but this is
an option so then the question is which
of the major built-ins actually make
copies and which don't
aside from sorted most of the built-in
they make copies are actually just
containers themselves and that kind of
makes sense if you ask to make a new
container using an old one then you're
kind of asking to make a copy on the
other hand there are a bunch of them
that don't make copies so enumerate
filter intermap reversed and zip any of
the dictionary views and Generator
comprehensions don't make copies once
again you can mostly tell by printing
them out
the ones that make copies look like
they've returned a new version of the
original thing
whereas the ones that don't make copies
are returning these special purpose
looking objects
as is often the case in Python though
there are almost always exceptions
you're able to change how a lot of
built-ins interact with your classes for
instance slicing a list makes a copy
because that's the behavior that the
built-in list shows but you can Define
your own get item method for your
classes and do whatever you want with it
and that's exactly what numpy arrays do
things are not looking good if you just
print it out both of these objects are
numpy arrays so you might think that
reversed is a copy but numpy arrays are
actually just very thin views around raw
memory and printing out the data
attribute of both of these arrays we see
that they're sharing the same exact
memory object contrary to the way that
lists behave no copy was made here
the way that numpy achieves this is by
using strides
strides tell you how many bytes you need
to jump if you want to get to the next
element of the array these are tuples
instead of just numbers because arrays
can be multi-dimensional
but for a 1D array we basically just
have a number the four here tells me
that from some element I need to jump
four bytes to get to the next one that's
because numpy chose a 32-bit or 4 byte
integer type for this array so all I
need to do to get a reversed array is
start at the end and jump by negative 4
for each element instead of positive
four
it's a very simple clever and effective
way to do things efficiently I wouldn't
expect anything less from numpy
and finally we spend all this time
talking about how to avoid making copies
of things but I have to say that copies
are not always bad sometimes you really
need a copy
the canonical example of when you'd want
to copy is if you're iterating over
something and mutating it at the same
time for instance here I have ABC mapped
to one two three
I want to go into the dictionary and add
uppercase a b and c with the same values
one two and three
seems simple enough iterate over key
value pairs convert the key to uppercase
and assign it the same value
it seems straightforward but we got
slapped with this runtime error
dictionary change size during iteration
if you're not familiar how dictionaries
are implemented in terms of hash tables
this might be a very confusing error why
does python care if I modify something
while I'm looping over it the very short
and simple explanation is that modifying
the dictionary might cause the
dictionary to have to move all the
elements around if that were to happen
then the iterator might basically just
lose its place
the solution is to manually make a copy
making a copy here means that we exhaust
the iterator and collect all the results
into the list
so the iterator is completely done
before we ever start to modify the
dictionary so there you have it I hope
this helped a bit
don't forget about the giveaway if
you're interested in a professional
pycharm license
of course thank you to my fantastic set
of patrons and donors
if you like my content hit that
subscribe button and if you especially
like it please consider becoming a
patron or donor my team and I are also
available for Python and C plus plus
Consulting
thanks for watching see you next time